there is something fascinating and
delightful happening since Herschel
Walker lost his election in Georgia on
Tuesday which is the Republican blame
game it's your fault it's your fault hey
who said not to vote early anyway that
wasn't a good idea why didn't more
Senators go to uh Georgia to campaign
for Herschel Walker they're all pointing
fingers and the most important takeaway
here to me
is this was something they brought on
themselves we're going to listen to all
sorts of different finger pointing here
we're starting with um uh Ari Fleischer
former Bush Administration official on
the Sean Hannity program last night
saying you need good candidates starting
to point to the candidate Choice and
then Hannity says well but the kid
Herschel Walker was a good candidate
this is the best stuff reason that
things are so close down the middle yeah
but the final point I'll make Sean is
mechanics are always important in
campaigns but candidate quality is
essential good candidates will win and
the big issue for Republicans still is
who is our leader who's the candidate at
the top well I will have this best
opportunity to bring people in so
Fleischer seems to both be saying Trump
at the top isn't great for the party and
Walker also wasn't a particularly good
candidate but both of which are arguably
true Herschel I thought was a good
candidate I know people disagree with
that but he got outspent in the runoff
about three to four to one he got
outspent in the general election by an
equal amount that makes a difference
money in politics makes a a pretty big
difference yeah so now all of a sudden
the concern is money in politics for
Sean Hannity because Walker was a good
candidate Walker was not a good
candidate but he almost won anyway
because the electorate in Georgia is so
depraved that they thought this guy is a
better option than Raphael Warnock which
is really wacky stuff then sticking with
Hannity for the time being Hannity says
you know in some cases maybe Republicans
do actually need to pick better
candidates and he says not Walker but he
talks about maybe Doug mastriano
Michigan in some cases Republicans do
need better candidates I'll give you one
example not to pick on Pennsylvania
gubernatorial candidate Doug mastriano
but you look at his position on abortion
he had no exceptions for rape incest the
mother's life you in Pennsylvania I'm
talking politically not morally here you
cannot win morally it's all bad
Pennsylvania Kenya with that position it
is simply mathematically impossible a
bad candidate for that race and it had
impact on the entire Republican ticket
so this is just interesting because
you've got Ari Fleischer saying Trump at
the top of the ticket isn't good for
Republicans Walker wasn't a good
candidate then in comes handed me and
says no Walker was a good candidate but
Doug mastriano was not a good candidate
the finger pointing is starting then we
go to kellyanne Conway and kellyanne
Conway's message is the problem is other
Republican Senators it wasn't Herschel
Walker it was that the 49 Republican
Senators didn't go to Georgia to help
Herschel Walker a new new Target of her
blame I think people saying we need a
new message let me just say something
respectfully to the 49 Republican
Senators right where were most of you
right why weren't you in Georgia a few
of them were but they all should have
been gentlemen because they should have
been there at some in some form a
teletown hall in person saying the
following I serve the United States
Senate with Raphael Warnock he's a
terrible Senator he doesn't represent
Georgia he's not fit to serve he votes
at Joe Biden he voted for inflation
reduction act it doesn't do that he said
nothing when they pulled out of
Afghanistan he said nothing that Joe
Biden's been to Delaware 174 days and
down to the Border zero days that's what
needs to happen where were the other
Senators to say I want Herschel Walker
not Raphael Warnock in the Senate with
me this is absolutely the best Okay so
Ari Fleischer says the problem is Trump
at the top of the ticket and Walker's
not a good candidate Hannity says no
Walker was a good candidate Trump at the
top of the ticket's fine but Doug
mastriano was a bad candidate and it was
money in politics that hurt Herschel
Walker kellyanne Conway says the problem
is the incumbent Republican Senators
they should have been there helping
Herschel Walker then we go to Mark Levin
Fox News host he points out hey
Republicans aren't explaining their
positions on any issues that's the
problem the reason people don't vote is
they don't have a reason to vote what
was the Republican position on inflation
what were they going to do I still don't
know well there was no position and he's
not wrong I mean listen Mark Mark Levin
is correctly pointing out
what were they going to do about
inflation now Herschel Walker couldn't
even understand what inflation was he
has no idea what's going on you know up
was down day was night it was for
Herschel Walker it was like a Twilight
Zone there was no way that's why Walker
didn't Express his position but why
haven't Republicans explained what
they're going to do about inflation well
it's because they can't really do
anything about it these things are
cyclical and they're Global and you need
to figure out what can we do until
inflation comes down Beyond we've talked
about what the FED can do Etc that's an
economic discussion but Mark Levin is
now saying they're not expressing their
views on issues correctly
and then the last clip here is Charlie
Kirk and he says Republicans aren't
voting because they don't trust the
process well why don't they trust the
process because Charlie Kirk's Maga
movement that he is a part of has been
saying you can't trust the process you
see
it's interesting I actually assumed
incorrectly that if you take time to
watch this program thank you right
that you would also just automatically
vote turns out there's a fair portion of
you that are completely done and that
are willing to voice that opinion why
would he think that his program which
endlessly talks about how everything's
rigged is going to encourage people to
vote
do we have that Laura Ingram clip that
we guys pulled
and I just want to say I do sympathize
with being upset with the Republican
party and not totally trusting the
system but not participating at all
guarantees the other side to be able
to play games and if everything was
broken and lost how did we win the House
of Representatives if everything is
broken and lost how did Ron Johnson who
stood up against the pharmaceutical
company win that was he barely won and
Charlie Kirk is Right Charlie Kirk of
course is right and I asked this
question in 2020 they say the
presidential election was rigged but all
the Senators and members of Congress on
the same damn ballots who won they don't
say a peep about those but if it was
rigged that how would there be some
incongruence
and Charlie Kirk is now realizing well
all of this talk about it being rigged
it makes people think it's not worth
voting and that is exactly what we have
been talking about for a long time so
the finger pointing is happening will
they figure it out before 2024 they very
well might they very well might we're
gonna be here with you until then make
sure
you were subscribed to our YouTube
channel three million people in October
we're trying to figure out we'll Gap the
number for November soon 3.2 million of
you in no in October watched our videos
on YouTube didn't subscribe
Please Subscribe it is free and it does
wonders for us in the YouTube algorithm
we'll take a quick break and be right
back one of our sponsors today is feels
feels is a premium CBD designed to help
you feel your best delivered right to
your door with everything going on in
our daily lives we all need to take a
moment to relax and that's where feels
comes in many people report CBD helping
with anxiety stress and sleeplessness if
you have aches or pains there are people
who use CBD as a safe natural method for
relieving pain without side effects
feels CBD oil is awesome the CBD infused
mints are great they leave you with
fresh breath you can try feels caffeine
free Focus melts to get you through the
afternoon slump feels even offers a free
hotline with experts to give you advice
about CBD dosage finding the right
starting point and when you you join the
fields monthly membership you'll save
money on every order and you can pause
or cancel at any time become a member
today and get 50 off your first order
with free shipping when you go to
feels.com Pacman and use the code Pacman
the link is down below